e
good good
morning uh welcome to Wednesday in
education um and we only have five bills
today uh so it's a light day for
us um and uh the first bill we will take
up is Senate Bill 217 establishing a
rural and underserved Area Educator and
sentive program for higher education and
making an appropriation therefore and uh
Senator uh Donovan is all ready to go
ready to go well good morning everyone
uh good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record I am
Senator Donovan Fenton I represent
district 10 and I am here to introduce
Senate Bill 217 which establishes a
Rural and underserved Area Educator
incentive program for higher education
and making an appropriation therefore
currently there are around 104 rural
school districts in New Hampshire with
many rural schools finding it hard to
attract and retain teachers Senate Bill
2117 aims to address this issue by
establishing an incentive program for
educators to teach in Rural and
underserved areas similar to a program
for healthcare workers uh to work in the
same areas this idea originated from the
commission to study the teacher shortage
uh which I was on and we can all agree
we have a problem and that is we need
more teachers this program is very
similar to what was passed in Idaho um
where they are also feeling the teacher
shortage and Nationwide for that matter
the incentive would include repayment of
all or part of the Educators outstanding
educational loans if they stay employed
with the same school or School District
uh this could not only help fill the
much needed positions in these Rural and
underserved areas but also help our
state mitigate the current teacher
shortage we are experiencing we all have
an obligation to ensure that any child
no matter the school district they
attend receives an adequate and
fulfilling education and Senate Bill 2
217 takes the necessary steps to provide
the school districts who need the help
the most with a tool to attract and
retain teachers I hope you will join me
in finding new ways to provide the
youngest granted sers with the structure
and stability we all know they need by
supporting 217 and we studied this for a
long time over this summer with the
teacher shortage commission and one of
the main things that came up when we
heard from educators uh superintendence
was uh loan repayment and you know the
Richer the the better off school
districts can afford to do this the
whole problem is that these underserved
and Rural school districts can't afford
to do this and the state needs to help
them and I'm with that I'm happy to take
any questions thank you Senator uh
questions from committee
members yes representative Belcher thank
you Mr chair and thank you uh Mr senator
for being here I I just can you talk a
little bit to um is there any sort of of
block that would prevent us from going
and actually just putting money directly
in the teachers paycheck or or some sort
of a bonus instead of going going to the
loan repayment that way they could use
it for housing if they need to buy a
house or anything like that or is there
anything preventing that no
representative thank you for the
question it's a great question I think
um the problem is it comes down to uh
the school boards how they pay their
teachers and local control on how they
pay their teachers and housing was
another issue that came up for the
teacher shortage commission we we're
looking at that as well um you
know paying is a sort of incentive your
paycheck is an incentive and this would
y yes representative
Hall thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question being here um was
there any thought given to a teacher who
let's say was working in an underserved
District or school and they get Rift so
they have to go to another District so
they go to another underserved school
not through no fault of their own they
could be a great teacher with any
thought so according to this they would
not be eligible in year two correct you
know I don't know that answer if they
would be eligible or not I think they
could reapply for the program um and you
might want to ask that question for
someone behind me as well um but I don't
see why they wouldn't still be uh be
able to apply for the program and and
just for the record folks um this has a
whopping $1 in it right now so um you
know the whole purpose of this is we
have the mechanism to fund this uh in
the coming budget we've created the
avenue to do that this is really the the
car to get us to the gas station have a
followup just so if they reapplied would
they be back at step one no they
wouldn't they wouldn't receive more than
their than they necessarily could they
wouldn't be eligible for to double their
loan repayment if that's what you're
asking no I'm just thinking if they're
sorry followup so if they're at step one
the first year and then they reapply
because they've gone to another school
are they at b or they at a this lines 24
and 25 you know when we're talking about
first year second year would that be
their second year even though they've
reapplied if if they if they completed a
full year they'd be their second year
okay even if it's a different school yes
okay thank you further
questions uh see none thank you very
much thank you all so much appreciate
it s around for a little bit
lad
good morning representative cordelli and
members of the education committee for
the record my name is Rick glad I come
from havil and I'm here today to speak
to
217 Senate Bill 217 in support of this
bill uh I was one of the members of the
teacher shortage committee along with
some others which are sitting on the
committee right now and those behind me
and we put a lot of time into this and
we do know it's been documented there is
a teacher shortage throughout this
country there is a teacher shortage in a
lot of those areas like math the science
and special education in this state and
there are shortages of elementary
teachers in this state in those areas
you can't attract them for various
reasons and I'll get into that a a
little bit later here in my presentation
I've handed out to you a article which I
extracted took out of the Wall Street
Journal dated March 5
2024 so this is just within several
weeks and speaks to school struggle with
teacher
turnover and as you read that they're
looking at 10 different states not New
Hampshire but they're looking at 10
other states which kind of you know
typify what we're talking about here and
one of the Prime reasons why people
leave districts is the
salary and the debt that they're
carrying and so I'd like to address that
because we do have a nationwide issue
here and we're seeing a decline in
graduates that are coming out at teacher
prep programs throughout this this
country and with that we're seeing the
uh number of programs which are teacher
prep programs at higher education
shrinking schools are divesting their
their dollars their funding and they're
putting it into other programs which
they see there's a high demand for there
is a high demand out in the schools for
teachers however there's not a high
demand from those choosing to pursue a
bachelor's degree in college is simply
because when you come out like my
daughter and my son and their sons and
daughters now are coming out and saying
I don't want to get into teaching I'd be
a wonderful teacher but I can't sustain
a young family with what I'm getting
paid and that's a fact when you're
coming out and you're getting paid
somewhere around 32 to $45,000 as a
first year teacher in the state
you can't sustain and we've heard the
issue of Workforce housing already
that's one issue but then we're also
dealing with the cost of just a young
family and and and the mortgage on the
house and the cost of the car and the
cost of the food and medical it it just
compounds to the point where people are
saying no I'm going to find a job which
pays for what I'm able to
offer so we see that we also see a
number of challenges that we've had to
address in dealing with this teacher
shortage and over the last four years
ago there were 400 Educators in
alternative Pathways to trying to get
certification we now have
1,200 in just four years that's tripled
and why is that because of some of this
debt the cost of going to school Etc um
we've also looked at last several weeks
ago a parttime teacher bill for those
teacher shortage areas this was a
recommendation that came out of the the
study group which we had which dealt
with this for the last summer and prior
to that in in the
spring and there were a number of
recommendations that came out we also
looked at this issue of what's going on
in our rural school districts in this
state what's going on on in these
districts were not not rural but they're
you know really hurting in terms of the
dollar availability and and that speaks
to it right here when we're talking
about those underserved areas which
might be a
Manchester and how do we attract people
to these districts and the way we're
going to try to look at it and what I'm
looking at it as we we looked at the
state of Idaho and this is just a
duplicate of what Idaho is doing so this
is not a political bill this is a bill
which deals with a real issue which we
have in my school district we have
wonderful teachers that
come and several years later because of
their debt that they're carrying and you
got to know that University of New
Hampshire debt is one of the highest
debts in this in this country but we'
glorify it by saying well our students
pay it back yeah and and they sacrificed
an awful lot in doing that but when we
have a good teacher arrive up in havil
you can bet two years from now if
they're great in the area of art or
special education they're going to be
teaching down in Hanover or Lebanon or
they're going to go farther south where
they're going to get the income that
they need to survive with and so and
where they're appreciated they're
appreciated in havil but you know the it
doesn't reflect that in what we're
paying
them so um there were several questions
which came up in this uh there was the
issue of uh should we rather than
putting the money as we have on page two
there where it's incrementally handed
out over four years should it be our all
awarded at one time part of the purpose
I see it from the rural districts we
want to retain people in the rural
districts we don't want to see them
getting in their cars and driving out a
Dodge and getting the job 30 mil South
we want to see them stay in these
districts there is a parallel between
those school districts which have uh a
loss of teachers and and it's more
frequent we're also seeing achievement
related to that you don't have the
sustainability the constant factor of
the teacher in the classroom you see
movement and where there's a lot of stop
and go stop and go in terms of you know
delivery of services the other issue is
what happens if they decide not to stay
in that school well if they're in a
school district like a Manchester they
get rifted they can this will follow
them any school in that school district
so you're going to this program follows
you in that
regard so um I I think this is a a
program which is absolutely needed in
this state and it's but in talking this
morning with director applebe over at
doe driving down the highway on
93 he said he absolutely supports this
program but in order to implement it
from his perspective you know yeah
there's $1 doll in this bill but he's
going to need as we heard just the other
day when we had uh Miss Davis in here uh
testifying on the bill dealing with
accountability we had put in legislation
from the policy perspective an analyst
to assist in getting that job done that
was struck it's no longer there Steve
applebe needs that help um several of us
in this room right now are working in
the education task force for higher
education the executive order of the
governor and and do and and Steve
applebe is the chair of that particular
commission which involves a a number of
people and I think we're coming out with
a fine report which we'll know more
about a little at noon
today but it took a lot of time on the
part of Mr applebe over at Doe and his
staff it sucked out about 35% of his
assistant time and they have all the
other tasks they normally have to attend
to certification dealing with people
trying to get into the business of this
he's also in charge of the higher
education and a number task they are too
skinny over there at the department we
really need to be thinking about funding
him the support to make this happen and
that would probably be if we look at the
cost of an additional person over there
anywhere between 140,000 and
$160,000 that's what we often times see
as that that factor um or the amount put
in by uh Miss Davis from Finance over
there so in conclusion I absolutely
support the need for this it's really
needed um we're addressing some of those
issues done it through the part-time
teacher we've done it through other
areas uh too but this is really a a a
good U way to attract and keep them in
our State and once they're here then you
get them for one two 3 four years in
those rural districts and that is in my
district that's important we have other
areas which are really short too
superintendent in my district the
superintendent is rotating out this year
she's gone and we had an excellent
superintendent But there again too
there's reasons why they're retiring and
one of them is you know uh there are a
lot of issues I don't want to go into
those right now but we have a shortage
there as well and shortage in a number
of trained people so let's start right
now and and if we want to see our
achievement scores really grow in some
of these rural areas where there's a
need we need to maintain consistency
with our teachers we need to attract
teachers highly qualified teachers a lot
of these people are just like the ones I
employed when I was up in Alaska I get a
good science teacher and four or five
years later that person with that
chemistry degree or that science degree
is working on a platform out in the on
the on the bay working for British
Petroleum or Arco or Sono or golf or
some of these oil companies which could
afford to Triple their salary just like
that so it's a competitive
market and if kids are what's important
and they are we need to attract the best
and the best qualified for the job this
will help us do that thank
you thank you um representative KC thank
you Mr chair um thank you representative
Vlad um do you have a preliminary list
of which communities would meet the
criteria for this I don't have that but
I know that Mr applebe does and he
couldn't make it today because the
report he's writing right now is due at
noon today where we'll be zooming and
listening to that report so he he has
that
information thank you I would say it's
well over half the districts in the
state okay thank you yeah representative
Woodcock thank you Mr U repres thank you
so much for uh bringing this forward um
I didn't bring It Forward the senator
brought it forward but I me your
comments of course the senator brought
it Forward uh the uh question I have is
two is one uh on representative uh
question about the number of specific
communities El when you said that um
that they have doe is it possible to get
that document it's already done yeah and
looking at these rural districts and
where there's teacher shortage areas he
has that information right he has that
information in terms of special
education The Sciences the mathematics
Career Technical education another area
in that Arena so he can just for that to
us we can have that I I can't tell you
when that would be available I'm not
going to speak on his behalf I know that
we have discussed this
information and it it it can it is
available okay and then just to follow
up on follow up oh thank you yeah on
representative Hall's question um under
that line 1920 here about if the teacher
Rifts out um to another school district
uh it it says is is there any way to
correct add that into this so it's there
in the law do we be willing to alter
that or be like it is if they're rifted
out
um in in my district I I've been in
districts where people have been rifted
you know and and U you
can when you write your job descriptions
you can fill a vacancy with the people
you want if you write it so it's I want
a Spanish teacher that's fluent in
Spanish while that takes care of but uh
in terms of the rifting business I I I'm
not quite sure as far as would this
count and go outside I don't think the
way it's written right now it would if
they're leaving the school district
right uh but my intent is that they stay
in that school district they stay in
that school uh so that's an issue which
is imperative for these rural districts
okay um and I don't think the rural
districts are really
rifting um the way they may be doing in
larger districts just CL I was using
thing as a term because that's what you
use rather if they choose to go to
another rural District they'd be
eligible under this grant it doesn't
carry with them that's just a concern
that's all cuz they're still they're
still an issue okay we want them we want
them to stay in New Hampshire we don't
want them crossing the line to
Massachusetts which is that's what's
going on okay thank you
yeah yes representative
bone thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question my question has
to do with um because there are so
little well there it's a placeholder and
there will be funds distributed into the
fund eventually um what if there are
more uh teachers that are eligible and
who would for this program than money
available are is there a priority
system I I think you're talking about
some of the issues that are going on in
division two and finance and on the
Senate side in terms of Finance
um I believe the money is there to do
this job it's just matter where are the
priorities you know uh
so
from a policy perspective I'll be there
voting for this bill um what goes on in
finance that's where we've always had
the issues the analyst was knock knocked
down and and
uh and of course we have the senator
right here he can tell you what's happen
on the other side it's some people are
projecting different amounts of money in
the education trust fund than on one
side of the wall to the other
side
yeah
followup um so basically what you're
saying is the intent of the bill is
where any educator that qualifies should
be able to receive the funds
correct yes anybody that's coming these
new teachers coming out of a cert with
certification they would qualify for
these funds should that money be
available and then $1 is not going to
make
it
represent you I I you know I applaud the
the fact that we're trying to help get
to feachers in these Rural and
underserved areas and certainly the
federal government used to used to do
this on uh Federal loans um for teachers
um I'm wondering about the Ed eligible
education expenses not everybody comes
out with uh student loans obviously
there are people that that don't that
make the ends meet but um you've got the
student loan or the eligible educational
expenses and then up in the definition
section it's the says means any
outstanding loan payments made during
the school year does that mean like if
they have a mortgage and they have a
loan payment on that I mean what you're
digging down and asking me a question I
haven't given any thought to and and I
don't know if I have an answer but I do
know that I had a similar program up in
Alaska where I was where a person went
to a rural district and stayed there for
a year their master's program was
totally paid for by the state with with
their housing as well so so they came
out one year with it all and then they
had to stay in the state a short time
thereafter I I'd also just like to
mention that um it might be good to
apply this money to the tuition costs in
the beginning to have a less tuition
cost in the teacher prep program uh to
encourage more people to go into the the
profession to begin with but but when
you put it up front then they use it
they trip out to Rhode Island they're
saying goodbye and then you're having to
chase this down I think you get into an
accounting nightmare trying to retrieve
those dollars you may never well I know
that follow
up yes I know that uh you know Plymouth
and Keane used to be primarily teacher
prep schools as they had in many of the
states and and once you were went
through that program you were certified
in that state so anyway just as a
comment further questions comments for
representative lad see none thank you
very much
Hawkins uh thank you Mr chairman uh
members of the committee um good to be
back here on second day second day in a
row um and very pleased to uh be here to
support Senate Bill 2117 um want to
thank Senator uh Fenton for um
sponsoring the bill um we started this
journey back in the beginning of
2023 um and so and here we are and uh
you know as uh representative lad uh and
Senator fenon indicated this was one of
the recommendations made by the uh
teacher shortage committee and um we are
hoping that um we can have this uh
policy in place so that uh when the
funding is ready whether that's this
year or in the in in upcoming budget uh
that uh the program is ready to go and
uh has what it needs in place um to help
uh address uh the educator shortage um
most of my testimony I think has been
covered by um the previous two speakers
I would just add um this is not the only
program related to loan repayment that I
think would take a similar Journey so uh
some of you may know that the Department
of Health and Services uh
administratively created a uh State loan
repayment program to help specifically
with um rural hospitals healthcare
workers um and to do so by uh creating
this loan repayment incentive um that
program um was
uh uh provides uh for those who work for
a minimum of three years in those
particular areas is um you'll notice one
of the rural definitions in the bill
references back to how they Define rural
um and um that was uh uh in from a
subsequent conversation with the former
director of that program who uh as I
said sort of had a similar story they
created the program uh there was very
little money in it but once they were
are able to have an infusion of dollars
it's it's become quite a robust program
in fact the Senate just passed I think
last week a program uh excuse me a bill
to um further appropriate money uh to
that program to expand the eligibility
um because they are seeing a success
with that program in in in helping um uh
rural Healthcare and so um as we've
talked about or you know the educator
shortage is real uh and we hope that
this will be um sort of a a major step
um toward addressing that and uh I'm
happy to take any questions um that I
can about the
bill uh thank you questions yes
representative Woodcock thank you good
morning uh just a question uh going back
on your your uh comment about the
success of the rural Healthcare program
you happen to have any uh information
from that background of what the
starting salary is for nurse of the
rural Healthcare has compared the
teachers um I I have information about
um uh educator starting salary I'm not
as familiar with um Healthcare uh I it's
definitely higher thank
you further
questions yes representative Cornell
Thank you thank you for taking my
question Brian
there the healthc care um rule is is
being successful they finding that
people are are staying or is it too soon
to say that they're staying after the
incentives end uh my understanding in my
conversation with the the the former
director uh is that they were having
success with people staying um I I I
kind of hearken back to um I'm not sure
if it was here or in the teacher
shortage committee but you heard from
the superintendent in uh the Newport
School District where they are really
struggling to find and retain um
qualified teachers they have I think she
said half of their teaching staff is on
site based licenses um sadly their
contract that was before the voters I
think it's one of the few ones that did
not pass this year uh in in March and so
they they so there is a is a real
struggle there um and so you know I
think of communities like that where you
know something like this um uh could
could be helpful one one thing um and
not related to that but I think there
was a question earlier uh regarding the
appropriation and the ability to live
within um uh the amount that that
hopefully is greater than a dollar um on
the on page two of the bill lines 28
through 30 um does allow through the
rulle making process the ability to
establish protocols for determining the
number of awards uh based on on the
appropriation and um representative lad
mentioned um the Idaho program so they
they had a very similar framework to the
guidance that was given to U their
Department of
Education and you know living within the
appropriation and what was passed in the
bill
they established a rubric for how they
would prioritize underserved and um
rural districts sort of like a point
system I brought some copies of that
with me today um the other thing I'll
leave the committee is states are being
have been aggressive in the last few
years uh in how in uh trying to address
this issue and in this particular area
um I brought some examples from from
other states of what it is uh they have
done um in in this particular area I
will say some of them have gone beyond
just the loan repayment issue um but
many of them have adopted
programs um that take some you know
portion of um
the uh pipeline of Educators to help
support them in those early years so
more more than you asked about but I
wanted to make sure I mentioned that
yeah any further
questions see none thank you very much
thank you Mr
chairman uh is there anyone else who
wanted to uh testify on Senate Bill
2177 see none uh thank you very much
we'll close the hearing on that bill and
uh we've got a little bit of time until
um we hearb
e
1045 we got 15 minutes oh wait it's
okay
e
okay this the 30 second warning we are
going to be starting here very shortly
it's just like basketball the buzzer
and did you watch the there
was
yeah
okay we're ready to go ahead uh for the
second uh hearing we're having this
morning it's
10:45 we're looking at 5:21 this is
relative to the educational credentials
for master teacher and I'd like
to welcome Senator
inisis Administrative
Assistant Grant
bosy uh good morning uh chairman lad
it's always a pleasure to be back before
the house education committee my name is
Grant bossy Deputy Chief of Staff of the
New Hampshire Senate and I am here to
introduce Senate Bill 521 on behalf of
Senator Dan Enis the Bill's Prime
sponsor New Hampshire's had a master
teacher certification on the book since
1998 as a way for experienced teachers
to continue their professional
development master teachers could help
their schools develop their curricula
and serve as mentors and supervisors to
younger faculty the problem is that
nobody gets one there are literally no
master teachers currently certified in
New Hampshire so the Professional
Standards Board is recommending a change
to a competency based portfolio another
problem identified by the Senate
education committee was the fee attached
to the master teacher application $800
is simply too high a barrier for
teachers seeking this path the bill is
amended would set the fee at $100 for
the initial application and $25 for
annual renewal the department has had
set the much higher $800 fee based on
the hours it estimated would be needed
under the current arduous process
Senator inis would ask you to consider
three things one this estimate is based
on the hours needed to complete the
review but the marginal cost is actually
zero unless the department needs to
bring in more staff the uh two the new
Competency Based criteria should greatly
uh reduce the time required for review
and three we don't actually know how
many man hours are needed since no one
seeks the certific ation now let's get
some Master Teachers certified and if
the department needs to adjust the fee
to meet the actual costs Senator inis
would certainly be open to amending the
law for more than a quarter Century the
master teacher C certificate has been a
road not taken for New Hampshire
teachers Senator inis would like to
clear the road so we can recognize and
reward experienced teachers who serve as
leaders in their schools if you have any
questions for Senator inis I will be
sure to get you an answer thank you for
your consideration and support of Senate
Bill 521
thank you grant are there any questions
from the committee on this Bill yes
representa Ry thank you thank you for
taking my question uh what's the benefit
to a teacher for pursuing this uh it's
professional development it's it's a way
that they can demonstrate not only
Mastery of their subject area but that
they are uh leaders within the school
they can help uh craft the curricula for
that district for that department they
can mentor younger
faculty um and and demonstrate that
there's leadership perhaps it's a path
to Administration if they want to move
up to be a vice principal they want to
be a department head uh it's hard to
know exactly what teachers are going to
be getting out of this because the
process has been so arduous that none
have tried so Senator inis would say
we've had this on the books let's see if
we can get some people doing it and
determine if it's a benefit or
not represent Woodcock thank you chair
good morning uh a followup to
representative D's question question if
there's no
um reward or incentive for this those
characteristics of a master teacher you
just spoke about are already in play in
most schools by teachers that step up
and do the work so why would I don't
understand the value of this um they're
already doing the professional
development they're already leading
they're already helping with curricular
development and take administrative
roles through their degree work and
through their uh years in the school
system so just I don't
understand if there's nothing of extra
value for this well there there could be
something of extra value if a local
school district wanted to
provide uh say salary bump or or extra
benefits for it that would obviously be
up to the local school district to do
this would be something the teacher
could have on their resume uh to show
leadership to another District uh the
benefits are really for the teachers to
decide and for the local school boards
to to decide if this is something they
want want to reward the state doesn't
pay teachers so we couldn't say oh if
you get a master teacher you get a
Fiverr uh or I'm sorry the state of New
Hampshire as a political entity does not
pay teachers uh or determine their
salaries and benefits so if um um you
couldn't simply say well you get a 5%
pay bump you get a $3,000 pay bump that
that would be up for the the local
school districts to decide okay thank
you thank you CH representative Miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here here I'm not sure you're the
one that answer this question but there
already is a national board of
certification of teachers that's very
rigorous I'm wondering if you know of uh
if we have
any teachers in our state right now that
are nationally board
certified I do not know I can check for
you okay thank
you further questions representative
Tanner and then representative leus
thank you thank you for taking my
question again may be more for the
department but uh do you know what the
process right now is to become a master
teacher I have the current law uh it's
uh RSA 1891
14f uh and among the many requirements
are a master's level or degree or
graduate coursework in curriculum
development teaching experience
including at least seven years with a
teaching certificate demonstrated
quality teaching to be satisfied by
meeting professional criteria developed
by the Professional Standards Board
quantitative evaluations of teaching
quality from students parents peers and
administrators at least three classroom
observations of the candidate by an
independent Observer from outside the
candidate school district and at least
four significant and rigorous written
tasks and exercises as you can see
that's quite a uh challenging obstacle
course I can leave this with the clerk
it's just a copy of the RSA um and the
Professional Standards Board is
recommending a
less arduous Competency Based uh model
to a base portfolio uh rather than this
rather extensive list of
requirements represent
leus thank you for taking my question do
you know if there are any rules or laws
on the book at the moment that would
keep a school district from paying these
license fees rather than the teacher
because it seems to me like it's the
school district who's going to benefit
the teacher is going to be working
harder so why should the teacher pay
money to work harder I do not know I
think the department could probably tell
you I don't know of anything that
prohibits the district from paying the
licensing fee for for instance the
educator credential is an annual I think
it's every three years that a teacher
would pay uh those are generally out of
pocket but I don't think there's
anything on the books preventing the
school district from writing the check
themselves if if they so desire desire
thank you represent Hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question do you think there's any is
there any incentive for the state to say
oh I have so many Master Teachers in my
state I mean is is that part of the plan
here because I I also feel like first of
all I never even knew the certification
existed maybe I should have but I taught
for 40 years and never even thought
about this but or didn't know about it
um but is
there you the end game you know yay we
have so many Master Teachers in New
is that I think that would be a benefit
I think as representative Woodcock
pointed out an $800 fee for something
with no immediate tangible benefit
nobody's nobody's bothered doing it and
I think if we lower that threshold we
can get some more people in and maybe
demonstrate you know all the experienced
competent teachers we have in the state
like followup yes quick I I'll say would
you believe I think we have a lot of
Master Teachers in this state but
they're not master teachers would
believe that so thank you represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question could you inform us about
master teacher programs in other states
if they exist and what kind of criteria
do they have and also what purpose does
it serve I could not at the moment but I
can look into it if the department
doesn't know off the top of their
heads are there further representative
Cornell Thank thank you chair lad and
thank you for taking my question I I
know that there are districts that have
people in positions just like this that
in Manchester it's called building level
instructional coordinator that do all of
this job that don't have to go through
this to be a master teacher so I I don't
know what the benefit of having to go
through all that to do the the job
that's already being done by someone who
doesn't have to do this yeah as I said
this is an existing state program for
Now 26 years ago this legislature
decided to set this up uh and it just
set the um the the obstacle course a
little too rough for people to go
through it so I think yeah a lot of
local districts are doing their own
version of this this would create a
Statewide version of it and use the
Department of Education to to certify
yes you meet the criteria as a as a
master teacher thank you just is a
little bit of a history on this uh going
back to the previous administration over
doe when we were looking at when we went
from No Child Left Behind into our
current uh Elementary secondary
Education Act we had Master teacher as
one of the indicators of the delivery of
an adequate education of of the of the
of the school districts but it was
eliminated seeing that the hurdles to
get master teacher were so high that we
had no master teacher so it was you know
it was it was uh deleted as a
requirement or one of those indicators
of we're delivering an opportunity for
an adequate
education which we've looked at those
indicators just the other day further
questions yes represent Tanner um
actually just a question on a followup
on yours I I just noted in here that the
that the master teacher rules that were
so strict and so stringent came through
in 1998 and and as representative Hall
said I taught for 35 years I knew a
couple people who had gotten Master
teacher but basically it was having a
master's degree and teaching a number of
years and and applying for it it really
wasn't as as rigorous as that was in in
1998 and I'm just wondering if you know
how that happened and why it happened
then so I'll I don't date back to 1998
but I can say when Jenny Barry was
commissioner and when Heather Gage was
working in curriculum all that's when we
took it out of the
indicators because there was nobody here
in the state
yeah I I happened to come to work for
the New Hampshire house back in 19 uh
fall of 1998 so I this had passed just
before I came
over further
questions thank you very much Grant
richson good
morning the red light has to come on on
your is that silver button there we go I
have the right to remain silent but not
the
ability good morning my name is IR
Richardson and I'm here today to speak
in favor of s SP
521 I have experience as an elementary
school teacher and a principal I'm
currently the coordinator of public
education and school support for NAA New
Hampshire I also teach research courses
in the doctoral program at Southern New
Hampshire
University for six years I had the
privilege of serving on the Professional
Standards Board here in New Hampshire
and while on the board I chaired the
subcommittee that worked to update the
regulations on the master teacher
license which had expired as Grant said
in
20122 the subcommittee met from mid 2020
through 2021 and we presented our
recommendations to the PSB in November
of 2021 the committee's recommendations
were unanimously
approved our committee began our work
reviewing RSA 18914 F that created the
master teacher certificate in
1998 the committee noted that the RSA as
Grant pointed out was very restrictive
about who could apply for the license
and the requirements for earning it the
RSA also gave the master teacher the
ability to evaluate other teachers which
we worried might contradict state law
within a bargaining unit as well as
negatively affect School culture
the committee did feel it was important
to recognize outstanding teacher leaders
for their leadership in their schools
their districts and the work they do
across the state when we began our work
we felt there were three options for the
irsa keep it as written and change the
regulations recommend that it be
eliminated and we don't need a master
teacher license or amend it and the
accompanying
regulations to ensure and you already
know this but to ensure that we wouldn't
negatively affect anyone who held the
certificate we reached out to the
department and said okay geographically
where are they are there certain subject
areas and they're like this is easy no
one's ever held it since no one had ever
held it this led our committee to
recommend that the RSA be revised if
we've had it for 20 plus years and no
one's ever wanted it maybe there's
something wrong with the
requirements once it is revised which
this legislation will do if passed new
regulations could be developed that
would hopefully encourage more teachers
to apply for the license the legislation
that Senator inis Ward Waters Fenton and
representatives cascaden lad Miler and
patrino have sponsored aligns with the
revisions that the master teacher
regulations were recommended to and
accepted by New Hampshire's Professional
Standards Board the proposed legislation
would allow for the development of a
competency based portfolio which would
include reliable scoring that would help
ensure that the master teacher license
would be held by Educators who had
already demonstrated their teaching
abilities in the classroom and their
leadership skills in New Hampshire
schools and
districts there are several reasons why
supporting the creation of a viable
Master teacher license will help
education in New Hampshire research
consistently shows that when leadership
is distributed throughout a school in
District student achievement increases
from my personal experience I think the
research shows this because the job of
being a principal requires being an
instruction leader being a facilities
manager working with parents Guardians
and other community members as well as
developing relationships with the staff
and students in the school it's
difficult for one person to accomplish
all these tasks well in a given day week
month or even a school year Distributing
leadership for the tasks like overseeing
the school's mentoring program
developing performance assessments that
will work in the classroom and being a
head teacher for a Content area
Department frees up time for
administrators to focus on other
priorities for the school the idea of
Distributing leadership to Master
Teachers has been done successfully in
several other states and I can speak to
those um because we did use their work
to inform our on the subcommittee it's
also been done here in New Hampshire
with districts like Jaffrey ringe and
conell who have partnered with Keen
state to implement successful teacher
leader
programs I also believe that when a
master teacher teaches in the classroom
and then steps outside of their
classroom to add their expertise to a
school district or state project it
opens up what I would call a career
lattice for them I say lattice instead
of ladder because being a master teacher
allows an educator to gain skills to
become an administrator if they choose
to but it also has them expand the
impact that they have on students
without having to leave the classroom
and there was some interesting research
that was done by the Met Foundation
metti Foundation where they asked a
thousand teachers would you want to have
combined classroom teaching requirements
and Leadership responsibility
51% said yes and then they said how many
of you are really interested in becoming
6% um when we testified before to a
subcommittee my colleague Emily Sherman
who's a stem teacher in Portsmouth
testified in support of this bill and
she couldn't be here today but I
promised her I would forward some of her
thoughts and she testified that many
many teachers have the desire to
continue to teach and also assume
leadership positions in a school or a
district as Department chairs mentors
and by working on other District
initiatives and in New Hampshire's
competency model that should not always
involve Advanced degree work if passed
sb521 will recognize teachers for the
leadership work they've already done in
their schools and districts it requires
teachers and CTE Personnel interested in
obain aing this license to document that
leadership contributions they have made
by creating a portfolio of teaching and
Leadership that will be objectively
scored both Emily and I urged the
committee to recommend that SB 521 ought
to pass and I would be glad to answer
any questions that you might have thank
you very much our uh represent Hall
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here Mr Richardson uh so I'm still
asking myself what's in it for the
teacher what's in it because innately if
you are a leader you're probably going
to lead in your school so so that part
one and part two would be um how does
this tie into the mentorship programs do
you see a master teacher being selected
to be the mentor in a mentoring program
that that would be a well choose me I'm
a master teacher so I would see that as
a possibility representative Hall but
not necessarily a requirement there are
people who are serving as mentors as you
know and by the way I think think you
were a master teacher um but there are
also people working on performance
assessments people who are working on
different District's initiatives so
there are three contracts that
currently give you additional
compensation if you are a master teacher
or have national board and to answer
your question there last time we looked
with 29 national board certified
teachers in New Hampshire many of those
came from other States and got certified
in other
states but if this certificate and
license existed and if it was a viable
then there could be ways that compensate
the people who choose to hold this and I
in talking with the Department we
thought maybe 1 to 2% of the eligible
people in the state would apply for it
which would be 2 to 400 Educators total
and what could come out of that would be
I'm applying for work in another
District or I'm applying to graduate
school so not only am I certified as a
teacher and principal but I also hold a
master teacher
certificate fur further questions
represent Miler thank you Mr chair and
thank you Dr Rich Dr Richardson for
being here your rep your rep
your your rep U nationally precedes you
into this position thank you um Dr
Richardson has been um noted for his
work nationally with uh professional
standard boards Etc so I have a series
of questions I'd like to have you
clarify you clarified one that we have
29 national uh board could you out could
you outline for the committee what it
means to be a nationally board certified
teacher and the rigor that it takes uh
to become one of those because I think
it is relevant to what we're trying to
talk about out here that's my first
question yep thank you and I should have
pointed out that Emily is a national
board certified teacher from her work in
Maine and now she's teaching here in our
state the committee thought there were
two things that we wanted to recognize
so national board is a national process
there's the national board for
professional Teaching Standards it's
probably about 500 hours worth of work
and about several thousand dolls to
apply for that certific if ification it
recognizes a teacher for his or her work
in the classroom in that subject area so
I would like to have national board
certification for my high school math
teaching most of the application deals
with what I do with students in the
classroom and so we felt on the
subcommittee that if you want national
board to be recognized for your
classroom work there certainly should be
a viable Pathway to do that although
this state doesn't um reward it as other
states do but if you said no I my
contribution is not only to my classroom
but I also work on assessment or I work
on the mentoring program or I'm a head
teacher for science at the high school
that we wanted to offer a pathway for
people to be recognized for their
leadership outside of the classroom so
we wanted a pathway which is national
board for people who want to stay in
their classroom and be recognized for
that work and a pathway for people who
choose to step outside and be recognized
for that does that answer your yes thank
you second second question second
question is uh it's more of a statement
I guess isn't it true that in some
states they basically provide funding
for teachers who want to pursue the
State Board the national board
certification one and two isn't it true
that in some collective bargaining
agreements there is a negotiated section
within that agreement that recognizes
that kind of achievement uh to provide
some at least some Financial incentive
for people to pursue those issues is
that true that is true in some states
like North Carolina if you had national
board whenever you were making it's plus
$55,000 they've since backed off from
that but there are states that if you
choose to seek that certification we
will support you
financially and should we go that route
I think there are ways that it might be
wrapped into graduate credits or
something like that through universities
which would help their enrollment and
would make it easier for someone to
pursue national board and finally um
isn't it true that to become nationally
certified I said as I said earlier is a
very rigorous process yes but in the
rigor of that there's also a lot of
professional development for that
candidate for that certificate and they
learn a lot and they actually improve
their own teaching as a result of the
portfolios Etc that they have to provide
yes that's built the reflection is built
into the process submitting a video tape
that's scored it's not just I fill out
the paperwork it's someone looks at it
and says yes this candidate it qualifies
for national board so my hope would be
that uh obviously I'm a co-sponsor of
this that the passage of this might be a
precursor to a more rigorous process
that the state might ultimately do to
really try to pump up the issue of
creating more Master Teachers recognized
by both from a certification standpoint
and also from a financial standpoint and
the issue of leadership within a school
as a result of that yeah I think you're
right you know since graduating from
Dartmouth in 78 in teacher rep one of
seven people who did that um I think
that there was this notion that there
was a pipeline where you drop in a
teacher and it spits her out as an
administrator on the other end I think
it's more like cascading pools there are
some people who really choose to stay in
the classroom and build their skills and
want to share those while working with
students thank you thank you very much
further questions represent
leus I don't know it seems to me like
we're going about this the wrong way and
saying teacher you apply and and get
your master teachers instead of saying
the school recognizes that we have this
person who in effect is a master teacher
and the te and the school does the stuff
to you know and might say we'd like you
to submit a a portfolio or whatever you
know can ask but it seems like it should
be motivated by the school and the state
especially if as the state wants more
Master Teachers it doesn't seem like a
person who's already working more should
be working more to get acknowledged for
the work that they're doing it that
seems backwards to me and based on the
things that you
heard when you were working on this
committee does that make sense or seem
feasible to have it
be the opposite because I know in a lot
of industry it's the industry that
grants the certification reward the
whatever that says you're a super
employee right of of whatever thing and
so this seems like a backwards way to go
what do you think um I think that's a
great point and we did come up with some
possible regulations but we didn't want
to get too far ahead of ourselves like
oh and this is how this could work if
the law wasn't changed then we couldn't
really put that into place but should
the law
change um we actually thought that it
should be scored by the local
professional evelopment committee
because you would know my work as a
leader in this District but because it's
a Statewide license that would need to
be verified at the state level so it
would be a combination of those things
and we
also um have some grant money not
through the Teachers Association but
from the University of Florida to field
test this that when the legislation
passes okay let's do a couple rounds of
you write a portfolio and you score it
and what do we need to change so by the
time we could hand it over with
Department's help on this process it we
would know that it would be a viable
process where the things my
understanding I was not involved with
the state in '98 but the things like the
standardized assessment of teaching by
parent that was never developed so head
mual decided she wanted to do it none of
that infrastructure was in place thank
you further question represent Terry
thanks when you were discussing uh at
the outset the process in which you
engage at the initial stage you
indicated that there were several
possible courses of uh action that were
um that were identified um was the one
that you chose the one that were that
has produced this product pretty much
would you say self-evident to you or
were there any what uh with respect to
any of the other courses of action were
there was there any that commended those
cour of action that you actually
discarded because you found this one to
Superior could you just drill down on
that a little more for elaborate the
three options were keep the law as it is
that was a problem for us because well
if the law current law and it's so
prescriptive about three standardized
three observations from someone who
doesn't belong in your school district
that if no one's held it in 20 years
that's probably not going to work so
then we looked at the field and like do
you want to have a master teacher and
they're like well sure what does it look
like because people did not know about
it and so there was interest but it
needed to change the law needed to
change so we looked and this will
actually I'm think I should give this to
you chairman lad we actually surveyed
all 50 states with the help of NASDAQ
which is is the National Association of
State directors of education and
certification and found out what are the
states that hold Master teacher licenses
places like Ohio that does a portfolio
and what's been their outcome with it so
when we found gee there are other states
doing it in different ways that really
let us down if we could change the law
then here might be a viable process for
apply the representative uh Damon and
then and right thank
you could thank you for taking my
question could you please speak to any
um perspective you may have on how the
prior or the
existing Master teacher process may or
may not have been communicated to
potential applicants and then parallel
going forward if this um Bill were to
pass what might there be to invite
teachers to participate how would they
know I'm not really sure I know it was
an RSA and there were regulations for
the doe I can't speak to how they put
that out there
[Music]
um I'm looking at representative
cascaden as a superintendent did we ever
get anything out to say Hey you have
teachers and I know you did who could
um and my immediate thinking about the
way to get it out is I know there are 53
teachers working on
Statewide Competency Based assessments
and they pull together work groups
voluntary work groups to work on issues
like that there are 53 districts that
have mentoring
programs and meeting with the doe in two
Fridays to talk about those districts so
I would say the yes there should be
General ways of getting the information
out but I also Target those people who I
think might already be doing the things
that we think would be good enough to
become a master teacher and asked them
to apply I would want to make sure that
we had a viable process rather than oh
maybe in six months there'll be a way to
do this hopefully we could field test
and get the doe to say yes these are the
regulations get the
PSB um to accept the regulations send
them to the state board and
get the word out there although I am
concerned I was trying to figure out who
was on the PSB for currently practicing
teachers and there's one teacher in
eight vacancies right now according to
the
website which made contacting the
teachers
easy who had the next question here
represent dry thank you and thank you
for taking my question so looking at the
current statute talked about um three
classroom observations from some an
independent Observer from outside the
district and you're talking about moving
it to
locally being done and I just wonder
does does the fact that it's got to be
verified at the state level then take
that element of you know familiarity uh
rather than impartial uh out of
that that's a great question I think
there are um what we should this law
pass is um be passed we would see that
you as a teacher get evaluated every
year anyway so why not use that existing
evaluations you would have had to have
taught for seven years so you've got a
record why do we need to bring in
someone outside we don't have a
Statewide evaluation model so the person
who comes in would need to know we use
Danielson or safy or whatever model we
use and it would be someone who didn't
know the kids didn't know the district
didn't know the curriculum who would
come in three times to say you're a
master teacher that seems a little
foreign as opposed to I've been your
administrator I've observed you for
seven years and then put that into your
portfolio without having to hire someone
to come evaluate
you further questions from the
committee well thank you very much IR
thank you I can recall when I was an
elementary principal up in Alaska before
getting in administration but principal
I had a budget where I'd look for master
teachers in lower 48 I look for
nationally board certified teachers I'd
fly them up interview them whine and
dine them uh at at our expense up there
that's when we were flooded with dollars
and employ them and it made a big
difference in the
school the one they came from well you
know I wasn't worried about that and you
know our achievement scores were real
pretty good yes funny how that works
yeah yep thank you for your time this
morning you're more than
welcome are there any other speakers on
this bill not seeing any thank you very
much we're closing this hearing and
we're going to move into the next
hearing which is 340 SB 340 relative
communication between parents and school
you got the floor thank you Mr chairman
two bills in two days to see you all
again uh I represent the people of gtown
hookit candy arond and maner District W
one uh this is a simple bill that was
brought at the request of
sau19 the town of gtown and their
business
administrator what this bill does
essentially is make it so that parents
can by default receive Communications
regarding IEPs via email versus via
postage they can still request to get
the documentation from postage that's
still an option under the bill but the
default would be via email the benefits
of doing this is that number one it
would be faster you know I can say that
I have a child who receives IPS
the um communication must be received
promptly it must be returned promptly
and having that happen via email is
Instant versus taking a day or two to
get to me a day or two to get back that
would be a huge benefit
it would save a lot of money there's a
this is not one simple piece of paper
back and forth over the course of the
year in some cases it's it's two or
three a month and so you multiply that
expense by all the parents receiving IEP
information it would save considerable
amount of money for the district um does
preserve the the option to receive
information for um IEPs via UPS uh
Postal Service and finally the last re
notification so people at both end know
when their email's been received and has
been read um and I hope that someone is
here from se19 to back me up on this
because it was at their request but um
this came out of the Senate on
consent okay thank you very much any
questions I got one question for you
when working with the the the districts
which this is coming from was there any
discussion regarding having to have
parental permission to send this
confidential information out via uh by
via the web uh uh before it was done
thank you for the question Mr chairman
there was some discussion of that in the
Senate hearing I believe you've accessed
to the Senate report um but no I have
not looked at that asking the question
yes sir I can answer the question the
assistant principal of Maple Avenue
School in Goffstown um said that se19
employs a platform which provides a
process for parents to confirm
information uh they can then updated any
time so I believe the answer is yes
thank
you further questions represent Celli
thank you thank you being your Senator
yes sir
um in light of what you just read um has
anyone looked into um uh Federal um
regulations regarding that because the
Federal Regulations require written
notice so I'm just wondering if have
there been any s anywhere in New
Hampshire or other states where um
written notice um might u mean um
handwritten or typed rather than
electronic communication that's the
first time I've been asked that question
but I can say that uh it my
understanding is that the vast majority
of parents do choose to receive their
communication via email when given the
opportunity um but the first few forms
still must go VIA mail they have to mail
me the form and saying is it okay if we
email you the information from here on
out I've got to sign that and mail that
back and then from then at that point on
things can happen via email but since it
happens via email already I don't think
that would be an issue thank you thank
you in your testimony or which you've
had over in the Senate on the other side
of the wall was there any kind of a
presentation from the Department of
Education special education regarding
the question just Glenn asked
there was no one there from the State
Department of Education to testify for
the bill either for or against all the
all the tested PE all the testimony
received on the bill was positive thank
you further question represent
whitcock thank you Mr chairman good
morning how you doing Senator welc see
you again um just a question is there
was there any dialogue I surprised that
Doe wasn't there but probably not um was
there any dialogue um at the testimony
about the implication of
deadlines uh from special education has
required parent parent interaction that
would may maybe negated dur by
Electronics or the timeliness you know
the 5 days 10 days 30 days those things
or all of a sudden it show up the night
before was any that that there was
significant conversation regarding
deadlines the importance because those
are statutory deadlines they have to be
met by the district and it was all
positive for email because email is
instantaneous as opposed to taking two
or 3 days to get to the parent two or 3
days to get back two or 3 days to go
back to the parent again email is
immediate so it it was strongly in favor
of email thank you thank you and when
they sign the parent signs it it's not
by a robot you know you got to do that
IRS other
questions thank you very much Senator
thank you Mr are there any other cards
referencing this particular
Bill not seeing any we're good we're
hearing next hearing is scheduled for
when
here so we have about a little bit of
had
e
that
time
sure
hello
okay we're ready to go ahead with the
last bill that's scheduled for hearing
this morning this is uh s SP 338
relative the education Professional
Standards Board and I welcome
representative Waters or Senator Dave
Waters I wantes trying SP a lot of time
I was trying to elevate you yeah I know
I know I know it's true it's
true uh thank you Mr chairman I think um
I'm uh Senator David Waters uh District
4 introducing Senate Bill 338 relative
to the education Professional Standards
Board uh the bill language it's itself
as you'll see adds a member to this um
board um and uh so we have two changes
goes to 22 members and uh adding the
administrator of the Department of
Education Bureau of career development
or
design
um it was you know not exactly an
oversight that such a person who was so
deeply involved uh in career development
was not placed on this board um this
recommendation does come to you from the
uh Career and Technical education
advisory Council and um I would just
want to note that of course the CTE
centers are so deeply involved in
student
credentialing um and consider an
inclusion of someone who could represent
them on this board uh fitting and um
there's some discussion about well
should we just say the um director of
the of the state CTE or a CTE director
and the commissioner Adu thought well
because the hierarchy and Department of
Ed is that because CTE is in the um
Bureau of adult education that would be
appropriate to phrase it this way but
the understanding is that it's quite
likely that it will be the design and it
will either be um Jeff beard the state
director or or select a director from
elsewhere um so that's what the way it's
I mean the intent is pretty clear but I
the commissioner thought this is the
best way to phrase that because of the
hierarchy of they're not being a you
know with the reorganization a few years
ago there's no longer a separate Bureau
for um Career and Technical education
that was folded into the um uh adult
education so that was the way that's
that's why we came up with this wording
but that that is the intent that the
people who right there on the ground
working with students about
credentialing and those programs I mean
that's that's what's so value about them
as you come out of them with a
credential and that there ought to be
somebody on this board that can um speak
speak for that group and and work with
them so Mr chairman that is the Bill
thank you very much uh Senator Waters uh
on that item e there where it says
administrator of the Department of
Education Bureau of career development
or selected local CTE director instead
of
design um the wisdom of this committee
is nearly infinite I I just I'm sorry I
just wanted to explain
why I thought I'd turn that
off my apologies don't don't appoint him
don't appoint him
okay um but I I I'm sure if that's the
change that you felt was necessary that
I I I would imagine the Department of
Education would see that as
reasonable uh further questions from the
committee represent Cornell thank you
and thank you for taking my question
Senator Waters um line seven where it
says b nine members representing
classroom teachers educational
Specialists or instructional Specialists
is there any designation of What
proportion are they Elementary are they
high school are they CTE
teachers thanks for the question you
know um since this bill only changes
that that one that one place I didn't
really look into the to the rest of it
okay so it's possible that they do but
um you know I think in terms of somebody
who is you know intimately connected
with what the CTE do is the point of
this and with the chair's potential
Amendment that'll be even clearer thank
you further questions from the
committee see your preceding
lunch that's always a good place to
be so thank you very much Senator have
Fowler welcome thank you my name
iser
fromes Sil button silver here we go I'll
start again my name is Ann Fowler I'm
the principal Regional Technical Center
and I'm here on behalf of nicta New
Hampshire Career and Technical
Association that's it comprises of all
our teachers and
administrators um with regards to this
proposed Bill uh our association has
taken a deep look into it and CTE needs
to be represented on the PSB uh the
professional standard board uh the
requirements and process for hiring a
CTE teacher is very unique and has many
nuances we have 28 centers over 400
staff
members th those staff members come from
industry they have very different
credentialing requirements uh different
backgrounds and they're hired because of
their industry knowledge their knowledge
of equipment their industry recognized
certifications and more importantly
their connections to the industry we are
CTE because of them our success is
because of them
ncka has tried for three years to get
somebody on this board
unsuccessfully um they've applied
they've gone through the formal process
and because they've been unsuccessful
they've even requested the open seats
there's been nine open seats um if you
look at B there's been nine open seats
and we still haven't been granted access
to sitting on this board so due to the N
requirements of our centers and the un
successful attempts in getting somebody
on this board we recommend that we
change the language in E to read CTE
license administrator currently employed
Center yep
CTE licensed
administrator currently employed in a
sounds like Steve
Rothenberg does it that where you get it
no I wrote it myself this morning
not all right and I'm done so if you
want any questions are there any
questions of Miss fer yes Terry uh so
you uh you you said that uh that you
applied without success correct on
several occasions yes years can you
describe the nature of that resistance
or at least how that resistance was
betrayed to you or was there just
silence um that I do not know I I'm
representing the association who gave me
the talking point that for three years
they've applied and been unsuccessful I
didn't ask that detail thank sorry
thanks yep Hall you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question you suggested
replacing letter e with the CTE licensed
administrator currently employed in a
CTE Center correct is there a reason why
you haven't is that different than
adding F or F would give one more person
I guess yeah right or I guess I'm just
wondering who the administrator of the
Department of Ed Bureau of career
development sure um can that be the same
person as the C no there are two
different roles um prior to my position
as principal of conquer Regional
Technical Center I work for the Bureau
of career development and that role uh
is slightly different they they don't
hire fire the staff members that are in
individual CTE centers they oversight
the quality control of how we administer
our programs the Perkins funding uh they
do monitoring visits but the actual you
know meeting with the individual
applicants in our role is at the local
level you know we're in our schools
we're in our buildings we're working
with the business community and our
neighborhoods um so when we have our
applications and we're interviewing our
candidates that's that's the
responsibility of the CTE administrator
so thank you yep representative Damon
thank you thank you for taking my
question so I'm wondering if you could
comment on something that we heard in a
prior hearing this
morning I believe the speaker then said
that um there's only one position filled
of the nine members it what's line b or
line seven um letter B on this bill is
that correct I I did hear that there
were many unfilled positions I didn't
get a quantity but there's many unfilled
positions and and that leads to our
puzzlement of why why they would not let
us sit on this board so that in L of
continuing down that path it's best that
we write it so that we have a position
uh you know on the board directly thank
youon
Woodcock thank you chair
I have two questions here thank you uh
notice you remember lunch I don't eat it
thank you oh you don't eat
Lun um thank good morning good morning
good morning um as someone who has a
wife has spent 32 years in vocational
education I I understand that and having
served on the school board there for a
different time uh I have one two
questions the first one is as you your
wording suggested wording for an
amendment or change to e
um the part that who currently serves as
uh a licensed administrator is it
possible just thinking I know sometimes
people around this table here are
uncomfortable having someone who's in
the field in the field um so I was
wondering if it currently served as or
who has served
as that if you have n you have nine
centers or 10 centors 28 c c so that
would at least give you 28 plus who were
there before to me yeah I mean it's been
my experience that the um the
environment that we work in changes very
quickly and when somebody retires or
leaves or moves on I would hesitate to
have them okay play such an important
role in this decision- making process
although that might be one more than you
have now right right right and the
second question thank you um and
strictly for my own lack of knowledge
had nothing with this well this I have a
this of one of which may be a CTE
teacher but if e is not phrased uh
licensed administrator because we have
I'm a principal right a different title
um saying director can also be
misconstrued as the Director Bureau of
credit Career Development I'm agreeing
with that I'm not trying to change that
no but that's why we said CTE license
administrator because of the allows us
the mobility that the CTE administrators
some are directors some are principal
so it allows to eliminate any
confusion yeah from that that's all
thank you because I'm technically a a a
principal and the technicality would be
to eliminate me you you have two hats
then I do that's right that's just like
your predecessor had yes correct
representative Cornell well this is just
a point of information I just looked it
up and the State Board of Education
appoints the 20
members
so
it's the state board that would apply
that would appoint the the nine teachers
thank you I don't know why they
haven't thank you any excuse me any
further questions for M fer state board
chair see see no further representative
Woodcock further question I I missed
whatever it was because I was cheating
with representative Damon here because
we looking at the law um research thank
you we look at the law it does say State
Board of Ed app points but it says
quoting D thank you I I associate it
quoting D it says um find D take off my
glasses from nominations submitted by
the education profession and interested
persons so it's really kind of so the
State Board of Ed appoints but doesn't
really give you the process of how that
D so maybe that's just just a point of
information thank you Mr chair thank you
uh see no further questions thank you
very much for uh being here and your
testimony um is there anyone else who
us yeah if I I may thank you um so uh I
a really interesting and helpful
conversation this suggestions that are
made and um I will suggest to um the
chair that he talk to the commissioner
and I'll certainly call uh commissioner
ad um because I I think the direction
that you know both suggestions uh do
make very good sense so let's see if we
can can't get this worked out but thank
you thank you and I I think that uh
closes the hearing on uh Senate Bill 338
and with with that we'll um break for
e
okay we're ready to go ahead this
afternoon with the last bill we have
today at for a hearing and that is SB
377 establishing the a achieve achieving
the achieving a better life experience
able savings account program
administrative fund and I'd like to
Carson thank you very much how it feel
be back where you really belong I know I
I I was going to say it feels a little
like deja vu I spent eight years in half
of this room on House Education so it's
a pleasure to be back um and I'd like to
uh say good afternoon to all the members
of House Education um for the record my
name is Shon Carson and I represent
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of London da Hudson and Auburn and I
have for your consideration this
afternoon Senate Bill
377 which uh tries to establish um the
achieving a better life experience for
able uh sames account program
administrative fund um I do have just
some of the testimony that I brought in
um and I'd just like to go through it um
this was written uh at the request of
the state treasurer and the director for
the Governor's Commission on
disability the administrative fund would
be separate and distinct from other
funds non-aps and furnished by
assessments on behalf of able
participants um I'd also like to just um
go through a couple things here um we
just the state of New Hampshire just
continued a six-year partnership with
the I Ohio State treasurers office and
joined a New Consortium of 19 States the
national able Alliance in October of
2023 as a part of this agreement New
Hampshire had the option to collect a
small portion of the fee charged to
participants which is $5 a year and use
it um for its own purposes since there's
no funding for this program New
Hampshire opted to receive the $5 per
year from each participant and the
monies will be deposited into this new
dedicated fund and the fund will support
the administration of the program um
there was also uh the language of in RSA
195 K2 colon 3 um which is basically
just um a housekeeping measure um RSA
K2 uh colon 3 already states that the
administrative costs will be play paid
for by the Savings Plan um at this point
I will conclude my testimony you have
our state treasurer here as well as Mr
Chuck seya um who will be able to answer
your questions about the fund so thank
you very much are you going to take any
questions I I can try but the experts
that the people you really want to hear
from are the people that are here behind
me so are we goingon to let her off the
hook that
fast that's okay I was on the hot seat
all this morning Mr chair and Senate
Edna
so okay that's okay well are there any
questions from the committee not seeing
you
okay Okay who wants let's go first
chucker
Monica we'll come together together okay
EAS
okay good afternoon good afternoon Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record State Treasurer Monica
mapelli and with me is um Char SE and
he'll introduce himself I'll let him yes
thank you Monica and good afternoon Mr
chair Chuck SE executive director
governance Commission on disability and
uh thank you for having us members of
this
committee yes thank you and and um so um
I know Senator Carson left but we want
just to thank Senator car Carson and the
prime sponsors of this bill uh this was
a request uh from uh um executive
director SE and myself to to um uh to be
able to amend this the current statute
um regarding the able um uh Savings
Program so
um as you heard from Sarah Carson the
primary purpose of this amendment is to
create a nonlin dedicated account and is
to be able to deposit a portion of a fee
that gets charged to Able Savings Plan
participants um so um just to um give
you a little background um as you may
recall the able savings account program
allow individuals with disabilities to
and their families to save for
disability related expenses and those
expenses uh and and those savings grow
taxfree if they use it for for you know
for that purpose to to help themselves
in for disability uh related expenses
and at the same time it helps them
protect their uh Federal benefits so um
so New Hampshire uh launched the able
program in New Hampshire in 2017 after
the able until the achievement of better
life experience Act of 2014 was enacted
in uh at the feral level so uh at the
time I pressor of the state treasur and
executive Chua uh partnered with the
state of Ohio to have um to to have a
program in the state um so that was that
lasted for about six years and um about
2 years ago when it was time to uh renew
that agreement and revisit that
agreement uh we decided to uh terminate
that relationship in join a New
Consortium which is the national able
Alliance um um executive um director CH
and I decided that that was a better uh
decision for the state at the time so uh
with this new contract um we do have the
ability to collect a small fee as we
mentioned and so that uh so we need a
place to deposit the money and that's
really what this amendment is doing it's
just creating um it will allow the
creation of a dedicate account so when
we receive those small dollars we're
able to uh have a place to to to put
them and to budget for that um so that
in a you know um summary that's what uh
this amendment is doing um I will
probably turn it over to uh for
additional sure comments and thank you
uh State treasur Mell why don't you move
the mic yeah absolutely thank you uh and
again Mr chairman and members of this
committee thank you again for having us
here today um as Monica had pointed out
we're looking at this as a housekeeping
um you may remember and members of this
committee who are who sat here back in
2016 2015 that's when RSA 195k was
passed which essentially brought uh able
savings accounts um to the state of New
Hampshire after was there was 2014
Federal legislation enacted um I will
tell you able savings account are truly
game changes and lifechanging for
individuals with disabilities because
individuals now have the opportunity to
save money as a state treasurer has
stated tax deferred and it doesn't
affect their uh potential for benefits
such as supplemental security income in
Medicaid so it really was a truly a game
changer so to have this program in the
state of New Hampshire uh is wonderful
um now that we have joined a New
Consortium um which the enabling statute
allows uh the state treasurer and I um
have looked at it in order to clean it
up because although the original statute
states that no General funds shall be
used uh to administer the program we now
have the opportunity to bring a bit of
funds into the state um which the
existing statute States but we just
wanted to clean it up uh so that's
essentially what we're looking to do and
I think um the state treasur has said it
very eloquently and we're more than
happy to answer any questions
thank you very much are there any
leus can you do me the favor of
explaining how the able plan works when
does it get paid in how much how does
that work who pays it in who takes it
out when all of that kind of stuff
because I've heard of it but I don't
understand exactly how it works thank
you so so for
um so I think you tried to I believe I'm
not to try to answer your question
related to this fund so not for this
fund she talk related to the actual
program this makes sense to me okay
perfect I don't know how the program
itself Works want to try to explain it
by all means thank you for the question
great question um and the state
treasurer and I are are always uh
entertaining questions like this because
as a state we want to get the word out
about these uh these accounts so
essentially if you are an individual
with a disability um you this person
with a disability can open up the
account in his or her own name there are
a couple of um criteria the onset of the
disability excuse me has to be by age 21
and also there are other conditions uh
essentially you have to be eligible the
individual would have to be eligible to
receive SSI or Medicaid supplement
security income so those are the basic
standards to up an account then the
individual with the disability can
contribute to his or her own account up
to $188,000 a year uh that that that's a
big deal because if you're if you're
receiving benefits such as SSI or
Medicaid there's a threshold that's out
there we hear the term $2,000
essentially individuals with a
disability can't have more than $2,000
in assets because it could jeopardize
Medicaid or SSI so in this situation the
individual could contribute to his or
her own
on an annual basis calendar year up to
18,000 or any family members and if the
individual is
working um that person can also uh
contribute about another 14,000 a year
so it brings it up to about 32,000 a
year which is again I we you know State
treasur and I use terms like GameChanger
it is a GameChanger because when you
look at it from the perspective of an
individual who has a disability parents
and family members were always and this
is across the board not unique to New
Hampshire had to stay under that
threshold the assets so and and then as
importantly once the money is in the
account and it's funded in all types of
investment options you can choose a bank
safe which is a traditional checking
account with FDIC insured or you can
choose various uh Investments portfolios
uh from aggressive to lease aggressive
you know whatever your tolerance is but
then the expenses have to be paid they
have to be related to the disability and
they have to um uh iner to the benefit
of quality of life so if an individual
with a disability um has money in the
account and now they want to spend that
money on what we refer to as a qualified
disability expense they can and again it
won't jeopardize the Medicaid or the SSI
qualified disability expense could be
education could be
Transportation um it really um basic
living expenses so it runs the gamut um
so that that's a very high level um
State Treasurer and I uh we present
often um across the state to to give uh
to answer your your question exactly
representative so I hope that helps out
and it does very much thank you
represent
Woodcock thank you chairman good
afternoon thank you for joining us um if
I read this right you have
104 uh participants now but your goal is
a thousand s right I'm sorry I I'm sorry
reading the docum you passed out yes get
PS okay so 104 partici now so that's
like $520 we're talking about here right
okay the scheme of things here between
the 34,000 and the 520 bucks um the
second one is the
um uh
participant at some point they pass this
is for an eternal right so if they stop
before 21 then go until 67 80 90 years
old is that the intent okay so when they
pass away where's the balance of the
funds go yeah did you like me are you
can yeah probably
you yeah another great question um
because the individual with a disability
is the owner of the account um you can
only have one account that's just
Nationwide it would go to the estate
process so there's no beneficiary name
that would actually receive it but again
that's standard across the industry so
okay I just okay perfect thank you so
much thank you Mr chair you're welcome
further questions representative
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question again referring to
the handout that you gave um the annual
account maintenance fee who receives
that is that the the Ohio group or
whatever yes thank you for the question
so so we we we work uh so this program
again we're part of a Consortium uh of
19 state so um the the state of Illinoi
actually leads um the group and they
contracted with uh a program manager uh
Miss sensus so as sensus is The Record
Keeper and and the manager of the all of
the program and then M chain the assets
for all the accounts so um so so as
sensus collects the fee from the
individuals um and and they essentially
they they handle the administration um
of the program so um in terms of how
this money is going to work they're
going to they're going to assess it to
the to the participant and it's going to
be um you know they collect what they
keep and then they send the small
portion to all of the states so we will
be receiving that on a quarterly basis
after as has after that fee has been
assessed did so they're sending you some
maintenance fee back to you as well that
is correct but you feel as though it's
not enough and that's why you're
assessing the extra $5 oh no we are not
assessing that so so this is this is
part of um essentially we enter into a
contract that was already established
that way so some states um collect that
$5
as well um some others use it to wave to
to to reduce the fee for the
participants um we we just chose to
receive the
$5 um knowing that it's only essentially
Chuck and I who manage the the
administration of you know this program
in New Hampshire so we we thought that
if we collected that uh $5 fee um will
at least grow a little money to be able
to continue to promote the program in
the state you know similar to one of the
things that we want to be able to do
more is is is promote essentially the
benefits of this program and and again
as as we heard before it's not going to
be a lot of money it's just going to be
um just some in there that will get
collected and you know hopefully we're
able to utilize it for the promotion of
the program for the benefit of this
program you have a follow up on that yes
go ahead so um once the partic I assume
these are like health savings accounts
basically um you know in a way yeah sure
so um once the person puts money into
that do they accruit interest or do they
uh actually you said investing yes so so
this this are savings accounts so these
are individual it's similar it works
similar to um the college Savings
Program the fighting United plan their
their sister programs that were designed
um they all under the same Federal uh
tax code so um so essentially the
savings accounts when participants um
the quality for this accounts um save
their money on them then they can choose
whether they want to um save it using
the checking account option or the
savings account option or they could
choose to invest their money long term
depending on how these individuals um
you know their their own personal needs
can't choose to either save for short
term or long term if they want to use it
to say for retirement I mean this is
this is the benefit of this accounts
there are a lot more flexible and is is
is it is for the benefit of the um
disability Community for example Savings
Program is only to save for college so
if you don't go to college then you now
the at the federal level trying to
figure out what else they can do with
those funds this one is very flexible so
uh individuals with disabilities have
the ability to just use it uh for their
own purposes to just um you know to have
a better life uh while they essentially
uh don't have to pay taxes if if they
put their money in those accounts or
they can use it for something else
savings you know for for on the benefits
so it's very flexible that's the benefit
of this
accounts if I want to open up a an able
account do I go to Fidelity do I go to
Wells Fargo advisors do I go across the
street to Banger savings what do I do um
to to the website so we have a so so
with this change of program so we used
to be part of the Ohio plan so we used
to be called stable New Hampshire plan
now our name for this this this program
sponsored by the state of New Hampshire
is called the New Hampshire able plan so
there is a website um and it's
essentially what we need to promote more
and I don't have the the link but
there's a website for this program the
New Hampshire able plan and that's how
um um you know essentially anyone can
enroll and open an account that way
there are a lot of um different um ways
to do it whether I think there's a I
think mainly as to this the enrollment
formats online right um and if I may Mr
chair actually if you go to nh.gov uh
right on the landing page at the bottom
there there are a few tabs the NH aable
plan is one of them right on nh.gov if
you were to visit the state treasurer's
website the treasury or the governor's
Commission on disability we also have
links right there uh which will direct
the individual how to enroll it's
typically done online um but there is
paper options also there is no um brick
and water so to speak in the state of
New Hampshire be because we are part of
this Consortium of 19
States so just to follow up and then
represent Dr um if I wanted to open up a
unique program which is for
education or in my case I have it with
the Virginia plan which through American
Funds but I do that through like a
Fidelity or through U American Funds or
through you know Wells Fargo you mean in
order to open up the able account here
I'm going to have to go that's the only
place where I can get at this is through
the web I can't go to you know uh um
some kind of a mutual fund or something
and and select
it that is correct so the so the only
place is is through our our um landing
page is the dis aable New Hampshire plan
and as sensus again as sensus is a
company um the manages the plan what
what the difference between for example
and I'm obviously we our college savs
program we have our contract with
Fidelity so Fidelity uses uh Fidelity
funds only um the differ so so so the EO
plan is different because a census is
The Record Keeper it's just um it's just
the company that manages the program but
the but the plan that the national able
Alliance has chosen to use different um
portfolio manager so they have Vanguard
portfolios or um there's the that I
believe the um um Sally May is the
savings account the fdac insure savings
account is a Sally May so um they have a
committee the national ail Alliance uh
has a committee that decides what port
what portfolios should be included or be
part of this plan so again um with with
New Hampshire we we our landing page is
is is that uh that's really the place to
enroll uh for these accounts so it
functions a little bit different yeah
gon dry thank you and thank you for
taking my question so if you are doing
okay advertising this with $520 if the
program grows is your your advertising
budget going to grow or will you outgrow
it maybe so this is the only source of
funds that we will have again the law
was was is restricting our ability
to um have more funds so this is the
only other extra income so obviously we
you know again Chuck and I we've been
leveraging uh and working with uh in the
past it was Ohio doing most of the work
so we we we we we are the ones that go
and and do presentations to various uh
disability groups so we we you know we
try to bring our folks with us from our
offices but this will allow us to have
just a little bit more to perhaps pay
for a little bit of you know a promotion
advertising or anything else so um in
terms of growing more it you if the if
the accounts if you know if we're able
to promote this plan to absolutely every
single eligible person in the state yes
our accounts should grow and the funding
should grow as well until we figure
something else uh you know what else how
how you know if there's another way to
grow our budget but as of right now this
will be again um we'll go from zero to
having a little more
represent Woodcock thank you chairman
just a clarification fall up and
represent D's question so I'm looking
now I'm looking at um at the in the bill
lines oh first one premise this this
bill um strikes out the general fund
meaning the state general fund right the
state money okay so there no State
monies in that um and it's in the bill
is changed the name to make it New
Hampshire able versus your H piece but
when I go down to 24 25
26 um wondering if I'm understanding
this correctly because initially I was
thinking uh as some may have been well
it's only 520 bucks it's just it's like
a contra he a buck to retain a lawyer
right type thing but then I'm looking at
three and four and do is this correctly
the money that you solicit through
promotion the GI else that also goes to
help pay for the administrative fund so
it's not $500 it's really any money you
collect in addition to that from other
from other uh
means that that is correct if we're able
to request grants uh or or or gifts we
will be adding those funds to that so
that right this this language and this
change will um will allow us to do that
thanks fa chair further questions is all
this money that various people are
contributing is it comingled together or
is it all together and the interest how
do you develop you know you separate the
interest when a person wants to take
some money out to buy something that's
eligible under the criteria that you've
listed how do they how do you proportion
out that interest yeah no that that's
what they do The Record Keeper um does
that census does that maintain separate
accounts is by law that needs to um they
need to have separate accounts because
they all have tax tax consequences so
they are you know every individual um
has a separate account and um as a whole
we you
know they are commingle because they're
tracking New Hampshire's accounts for
example but um um in um there is a trust
the funds need to be in a trust and they
all going and they all essentially sub
trust for each fund for each state each
state has a sub Trust of this one called
trust if that makes sense sounds like
Mary Guile's old Bill remember that
folks yeah in education um further
questions from the committee yes
represent Tanner thank you I
just how come this is an education
rather than like Health and Human
Services
or what's the connection with education
I think if I may and I could be wrong um
I think it's where 19 where the bill was
originally placed what
195k it falls under education but I
don't know
okay wheelchair so if I want to buy a
new car and I need to get all the
handicap
associated equipment in that car I could
use this fund to do that well yeah it
again it would have to pass what we
refer to as Mr chair uh the two prong
test is what you're looking to do
related to the disability based upon
what you said it would be and the second
part of the two-prong test does it look
to benefit health and Independence and
quality of life for the individual with
a disability I would say yes yeah it's
very broad application yeah yeah which
which is a good thing yeah yeah yeah
represent Woodcock La last comment Mr
last question so I just want to CU the
numbers keep on keep on looking at these
numbers um so if I understand the
capacity here if the capacity was
34,000 between the work and the 18,000
donation and you're looking
at goal initial goal is a th000 uh
clients participants annually so you're
basically talking about a potential of
$34 million per year funding is that
right
think so I don't believe so so so right
now is my math wrong it's modern math
yeah no no no no no no Hightech
man that that can be my problem is that
right the 34,000 I think you need to
share your tips on your math it might be
helpful for other
purposes um no I think um just to
clarify we don't ever expect um that
much money um so for example to give you
an example this is what we we we I think
we mentioned it as well maybe I wasn't I
wasn't clear enough but for example with
um with the stable um account program um
right now because those accounts stay
there uh we couldn't we couldn't
transfer those accounts and Hampshire
accounts to this new program so um over
the course of um six years a thousand
accounts um became part of that program
so those folks are there and until we
they either choose to change or um you
know we continue to promote the fact
that we have a new SP New Hampshire
sponsor plan but so so just to give you
an example when we when we uh we were
looking at the number of accounts uh
Chuck and I when we um provided
testimony to the Senate we had because
it was a brand new plan we had uh 14
accounts and today we check the numbers
and we have 104 accounts so we expect
that this as again as this um program
it's it's is gets more known and and and
so we expect to to add more accounts but
it wouldn't be um no what would you say
is is the number the eligible
individuals in New Hampshire see we
don't have a direct figure with that
Monica so roughly there's a $1.3 million
um
1.3 that that's the residency of New
Hampshire but that's our population and
roughly one in8 individuals per the
institute on disability report having a
disability so it's like one in8 so we
have about
173,000 individuals per per the census
per the IOD Institute on disability that
states it's an individual with a
disability whether or not they meet the
criteria of onset of disability by age
21 we can't determine that we but again
that's that's the total population of of
an individual with a disability
173,000 um I I think and if I may so we
again I know these are great questions
and so when we first launched the
program so that would have been in
2017 um as a state treasur as as stated
we were with the state of Ohio and the
program then was known as stable NH um
this past October the uh cont we decided
State treasur and I heard the statute we
we looked at other programs we vetted
them out across the country and we
decided to join a new platform
right now there are roughly I would say
just over a thousand accounts that are
remain with the state of Ohio because
they had joined state of Ohio either
back in 2016 or 2017 when we launched
but now New Hampshire has chosen a new
platform and that's where we have the
104 so essentially from 17 to say this
past October we got to that thousand
accounts and now we're whether or not
they roll over that that's up to them I
mean Ohio is a solid program um but this
is the new program in New Hampshire so I
think I don't know if that helps out
representative we we're not we anticip
we needed a vehicle when I say we State
treasur and governance Commission on
disability needed a vehicle to now
accept this $5 fee annually um per
account it is annually per account and I
I think I mean it will be um I think
what we hope and anticipate is perhaps
if if the plan land grows to another a
th000 accounts so we are able to collect
about $5,000 per year that would be you
know what we are
anticipating but the account value the
the account value goes up sure
depending what that's right the 34,000
is with working in the contribution the
18 plus the 14 that's right I appreciate
the program and thank you for the ANW I
understand this is brand new so we're
we're thank you Mr chair love questions
are there any other questions from the
committee
not seeing I want to thank you for
coming in today thank you Mr chair you
very much for your time yes you're
welcome are there any other pink cards
on this
hearing the day yeah we're closed down
the
date yeah
all
there she's taking video of the
yeah
e